do you ever how often do you reminisce
how often do you think of like oh man
those were the years do you think like
that do you think oh when you're a kid I
miss this and I missed so and so I
wonder what they're doing do you like
almost are you do you live in the past
at all or are you more of like that's
the rear view mirror I ripped it off I
live in today I don't ever ever look
back and if I do it's rare
I think
um
I'm I'm sentimental like I look back on
things sort of fondly like I'll remember
like oh we were friends when we did that
and sometimes you'll know that it's a
set friendship and not a life friendship
and you sometimes know that like in real
time yeah and that's totally okay I'm
never someone who's like I don't chase
friendships or whatever but that's the
only thing that I think I feel
sentimental about is sometimes like the
people like oh we hadn't experienced
together but what I really love about
again being in the game for a really
long time is that when you do get to
reconnect with people like we're doing
today is that like when you get to meet
someone when you're oh my God like 17 20
whatever and then again when you're in
your 40s like somewhere you get to meet
someone again you get to meet someone
twice in a lifetime you're like Hello
nice to meet this version like Freddie
Prince oh my God you haven't seen him in
how many years right he's exactly the
same he's a bad example of this story
but examples okay now Freddie's always
been so true to himself has he been on
this show
I hadn't asked him but I'd love him to
come on he's so candid and so funny I
feel like would he come on totally all
right I'll help you'll help me you know
I'm sure you've met like by I think we
might have met years and years ago I
mean I don't know he has some of the
best stories does he that yeah yeah I'm
not sure he would tell us move him on
record but I hope you guys get a drink
someday